kelly is with us to start off this hour
in houston
hi kelly how are you hi dave how are you
better than i deserve what's up um well
my ultimate question is i want to know
if um it would be an option for us to
cash out our 401k which has roughly
about 35
000 in it in order to pay off credit
cards and
get into a new home by um
school year next year um the reason why
is our landlord has let us know that
rent will be going up in august
to basically what a mortgage would be
for us and
also uh we were going to do two years of
pre-k to give us another year
and now pre-k has also let us know that
the tuition will be going up 400
next year as well so i just wanted to
know what your thoughts were on cashing
out the 401k
in order to pay off debt get into a home
in a better school district ultimately
as uncle
what's your household income um i would
say about 95 000
okay that's good news how much do you
owe on your cars
um we have two vehicles we owe about 14
on each of them okay 14 on each
and you have how much other debt other
than your vehicles in your house
you don't have a house well we only have
credit card debt lost and then the cars
um we were doing your debt snowball and
we were
really doing great at it and then in
august we went on a vacation
my husband's company lost his client
and why did you go on vacation when you
were doing the death snowball
um well my family is cross country and
we have kids
so it's kind of we actually did save up
cash to do it
so we we didn't feel as bad as doing it
we worked it into our budget
in order to be able to do it um
but you're broke yeah
you're deeply in car debt you're deeply
in credit card debt
and you can't afford to go on vacation
and you don't own a house
yeah yeah okay here's the problem you
guys are in a 40
tax bracket and so um any money you pull
out of there is going to be taxed at 35
to 40 percent
plus a 10 penalty so the government's
going to take
roughly half of whatever you pull out of
your 401k
okay and so that's kind of like saying
dave
i want to pay off my credit cards and
buy a house with a 40
interest loan
normally i wouldn't even think about
doing it normally that would be stupid
and abnormally that would be stupid in
any category that would be stupid
unless it was to avoid a bankruptcy or
foreclosure you would never borrow money
of 40
interest there's just no way
now if you want to move to a school
district
and rent move but you're broke you don't
need to be buying a house
any more than you need to be going on
vacation you guys make too much money to
be this broke it is time for you all to
get your crap together
well in that and that we were we really
really were
and then when we came back from the
vacation and you quit my
husband's company lost his client we
actually ended up taking a
about a two thousand dollar a month
fixed
so where we were really getting into the
death snowball and being able to pay
things off
and really doing well at it all of a
sudden it came to
you quit well now we can't make it we're
having
yeah you quit probably
sorry get together you quit so you've
got to get back on
you don't have a choice you guys are
you're broke
and you're running around supporting
this lifestyle with credit cards
and with car loans that you can't afford
you make ninety thousand 000
a year and you're broke
so it's it's time it's time for y'all to
roll up your sleeves i don't care if you
move to a cheaper rental
or move to the school system you want to
move to and rent again but you're not in
a place to buy a car
buy a house or go on vacation well
that's the whole thing
is the reason why we weren't going to be
moving is because
our rent currently is only a thousand
fifty and we
we were like so why don't you just stay
there
he's going up well because he's going to
raise it up to
um about 15 to 1600 a month
and look for another place the school
that we are actually in the overall test
scores for these schools are
60 i don't care you're broke
i don't care what the test scores are go
rent a house somewhere
you cannot buy a house kelly you're
going to destroy your life
you're going to make a mess and i'm not
going to be part of it i'm not going to
tell you
under any circumstances this is smart
now you got house fever kiddo go take a
cold shower
you're broke you're broke
you're a 90 000 household income that
has no
freaking money you owe 28
000 on your cars thousands of dollars on
your credit cards
i don't give a crap about test scores go
rent a house somewhere rent that house i
don't care which one
but get yourself on rice and beans beans
and rice you don't need to be cleaning
out your 401k
and adding to the stupid sauce a bar
taking a
40 hit on your money don't do it
please please don't do it
it's you're destroying your life by
making stupid financial decision after
stupid financial decision
stop it stop it all right
i'm gonna help you i want you to go
through financial peace university our
nine week class
because you got to get some support
around you guys so you can emotionally
shore yourselves up
to stay on track everybody runs into
hard times while they're going through
the dead snowball
but you got to stay on or if you get
bumped off the wagon you jump back on
the wagon
and you chase that wagon down and you
tackle the horses and you climb back in
the wagon
you do not let this wagon get away from
you again i don't care if your husband
loses a client
i don't care if your family's across the
dadgum ocean i don't care if there's
test scores in the
three three blocks over i don't care
it's time for y'all to get your act
together
because you're destroying your lives and
your future with this
you're so broke and you can't breathe
you don't have any options
because you've spent spent spin spin
spent and you got to stop it
you got to stop it hold on kelly's going
to pick up i'll put you through the
class honey i'll walk with you
but i'm going to be your boot camp i'm
going to be your sergeant man
you're in boot camp i'm going to i'm
going to
help you do this stuff i'm going to
coach you i am not going to participate
in your insanity
don't do this don't do this
hold on kelly'll pick up hey guys thanks
for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button
to get the latest content and check out
these other great clips
from the show you are not a victim
you're not a victim of big corporations
you're not a victim of wall street
you're not a victim of capitalism you're
not a victim of wealth inequality
you're not a victim of racism you're not
a victim
you